if I had to pick one word to describe
weworks
2019 it would be cluster so we were
started the year pretty strong in
January they announced that Softbank had
completed a six billion dollar
investment in the company which valued
it at a pretty stunning forty seven
billion dollars and that made it the
second most valuable startup in the
country behind uber at least on paper at
the same time they announced a new
umbrella organization called the Wii
company which would encompass of course
we work the main co-working business as
well as an apartment concept called we
live Jim called we rise a retail concept
called made by we and most
controversially we grow which is a
experimental school that was started by
CEO Adam rumens wife Rebecca because
sort of auxilary we brands exist on a
small scale Ben really scaled and in a
meaningful way it plays into this whole
vision that if you take out about his
word has been around since the very
beginning when the company was founded
in 2009 to kind of create community
across all sorts of verticals so after
this off being investment that valued we
work at 47 billion dollars Forbes
estimated that CEO Adam Newman was worth
about 4.1 billion dollars most of that
and his day in the company but at the
start of 2019 there there was concerns
but these these two bits of news were
relatively positive at least to sort of
a casual observer I mean when you looked
under the hood in hindsight some of this
stuff was clearly problematic at the
time when they announced the Wii company
they also made Rebecca Adams wife a
co-founder which at the time raise some
eyebrows but some of the effects of that
wouldn't become clear until until
on when we were confirmed in April that
they had filed confidentially to go
public it caught people at high surprise
they were losing a ton of money in 2018
we work had revenue of 1.8 billion and a
loss of 1.9 billion so their loss laughs
to their their revenue and there wasn't
sort of a clear plan of how they would
become profitable reporters across the
country really wanted a full gear I'm
trying to get the dirt on this company
because there's been so much whispering
about their oddness it came out that
Adam Newman owned properties that he was
leasing back to we were and making money
and he had cashed out something hundreds
of millions of dollars which is unheard
of startup founders don't do that I mean
they'll take a little bit of money to
live off of but when we talk about these
huge networks that the that private
company founders have it's a lot of it's
on paper they don't have that money the
paperwork was finally released at 7:07
in the morning on August 14th it was
pretty clear immediately that this was
not your your average s-1 its document
rather than clarifying really confirmed
a lot of people's worst fears about this
company these are formal documents these
are filed with the Security and Exchange
Commission so normally you would see
people the CEO and different executives
and really anyone name referred to by
their last name this document it
mentions Adam a hundred and sixty nine
times there were some details about an
Adams relationship with the company he
didn't have a formal employment
agreement with them all of the
executives had agreed to give over their
voting shares to him so we have this
incredible power and probably the two
most surprising things to me were one
night what would happen if Adam Lee died
or could not serve as he
anymore and that was his wife Rebecca
she would be one of a very small group
of people who would choose his successor
that's very unusual it's usually a whole
board it's usually huge search
committees the idea that a founders wife
could decide who would run the company
when he couldn't it was not not the norm
so the other surprising detail in the S
alone was that I didn't had the
trademark for the word we and when they
rebranded as the week company he had his
company pay him almost 6 million dollars
to use the word we
it struck people as being milking this
company for everything he could get out
of it and it was particularly ironic
when it's this company about claims to
be all that community in subsequent
rewrites of the s-1 the company tried to
correct for a lot of this and it just
was never never enough they were losing
so much money but losses had the losses
had expanded in the into 2019 investors
just weren't haven't yet and then kind
of a final straw seemed to be in
September when the Wall Street Journal
did this great report on Adams behavior
and and there had certainly been reports
and stories before about his drinking
and partying and the lead of this was he
was getting high on a borrowed private
jet and it just really seemed to be a
final straw for a lot of people in
mid-september and the IPO was postponed
and within a week Adam Lewis was forced
out we were still needed the money that
they were hoping to get from this IPO by
October there were signs that they only
had enough cash on hand to run the
company for a few more weeks so on
October 22nd Softbank announced a nine
point five billion dollar bailout
package
and about time on the span the company
went from being worth 47 million dollars
to worth less than a billion dollars and
what was kind of most galling to a lot
of people about this deal was that Adam
Newman got this sweetheart package all
in valued at 1.5 billion dollars that of
course coincided with the really most
painful part of all of this which is
right around Thanksgiving we work laid
off 2,400 people and that was famous to
me
across the organization but last week I
got an email from one of their
communications people with the press
release we work opens monthly record
number of new buildings and it two weeks
earlier they'd laid off 2,400 people I
don't know if they're that strap that
means our strategy is to try and like
turn the page and I move on and they
have for the time being they have some
money to kind of write this yet but
there's gonna be more hard cuts to table
whether that means more layoffs I don't
know but they're divesting some of the
startups they had acquired over the
years in December there was news that
one of those startups was being bought
back by the founder it's easy to kind of
laugh at this misfortune and in
hindsight he could have seen it coming
but there's a lot of people who lost
their jobs and there's the way everyone
works and some way now comes from what
we work did and now the people at we
work are not sure that they'll ever get
that back
[Music]
you